David de faria is an attorneys or former
Obama campaign advisor anything to
insist David thanks so much for coming
on
so moments like this are so instructive
because they really do divide the world
into very clear sectors you sort of know
who's on his side and I find this
interesting because the rationale has
changed so people are saying you know we
need to fight Isis but that's not really
the point the point is to counterbalance
Russia and Iran and I'm wondering is
that a our goal be achievable with 2,000
troops in Syria like what actually is
the goal I'm losing track well they're a
couple goals it's it's to fight Isis
it's also to push back on Iran and on
Russia
so what's stunning about this
development is all of president Trump's
foreign policy advisors and top military
advisors were against this decision and
he reversed them today suddenly in a
rash decision now the reason why we
should stay you say your people who
think we should stay in Afghanistan
right reasons are different okay Trump's
top policy adviser said we are gonna
stay in Syria until we have one rolled
back Iran that has not happened to
defeated Isis we have made major
progress in fighting Isis but we haven't
fully defeated them I was in Iraq in
October nobody on the ground in Iraq
tells me we defeated Isis there and Isis
is even stronger in Syria still more
over that all of trumps policy advisors
has said we should stay in sear until
there's a political solution in Syria
none of those three things that wouldn't
wouldn't it be a wrong thing is that can
I just show that's maybe another option
so there wasn't actually Isis in Syria
when the Assad government controlled the
whole country Christians and other
religious minorities a lot of them lived
in relative peace now they're hunted
down and murdered why wouldn't it just
be the simplest most elegant best
solution for everyone involved if Assad
managed his entire country because
you're ignoring the history and the
development of the revolution in Syria
the revolution in Syria just happened a
few it happened organically it began in
2011 it happened organically right and
so Syria was an authoritarian state
before that with tons of oppression
maybe Christians were okay there's there
another people or not he's there
inaudible
is there a non authoritarian state in
that region or than Israel there are
there are less authoritarian States
Jordan's an authoritarian state
criticize the king and see what happens
so like it's that's the one where Jordan
to Syria to Iraq
I'm just saying authoritarian justifies
nothing they're all authoritarians okay
but the point is that this was an
organic revolution the US didn't start
this revolution it started by the Syrian
people majority of whom are Sunni Arabs
they stood up against Assad he chose
rather than to Rick reconcile with them
he chose to mow them down and slaughter
tens of thousands of innocent peaceful
protesters that's how the revolution
sighs okay but I'm not defending Assad's
character I'm merely saying for good
respect why should I yeah I'm not Syrian
I don't work for Assad I'm an American
and I want to know what's best for us
and if you're worried about the chaos
and the huge refugee problems caused by
the Civil War and by the emergence of
Isis again abetted by this of war then
why wouldn't you long for the days where
Christians could live unmolested in
Syria under this authoritarian Assad I
know I'm totally missing it what about
is not this is actually going to cause
more refugees okay
northern northeastern Syria right now is
secure the reason it's secure is because
of the great work by our US Special
Forces working with the SDF the local
Syrian and moderate Sunni forces on the
ground they've secured it and actually
there are less refugees coming from that
area the people can say they're not
getting bought out of the garage and
when we pull out when we pull out it's
going to cause a massive wave of Syrian
refugees again because the forces are
gonna go in and slaughter the forces
that we've been working with on the
ground yes Assad's forces Iranian Shia
militia forces and possibly even Russian
forces okay and so we're responsible for
that because so this is halfway around
the world we have crises like
Venezuela's collapsed it's right there
Mexico has probably as many murders to
Syria I mean not close right so like I'm
just saying there a lot of things going
on but we have a moral obligation to
keep 2,000 American troops in this
country around the world cuz why I'm
honest I'm confused
well first of all we are there already
and
successful so why pull out we also do
have some obligation of the forces on
the ground cessful
who fought bravely alongside us moreover
this is going to impact us because Isis
will come back and if we don't have
forces on the ground to monitor Isis and
to continue to combat Isis Isis will
come back Isis are sworn enemies of the
US they want to kill Americans where
they become stronger in Syria they'll
strike out against America your viewers
should worry about their own security
because of this decision well there are
a lot of reasons to worry about our own
security a lot your many and our mental
health and our economy and our health
care says a lot of things to worry about
but by the standards that you've just
articulated like we're never gonna leave
there or Afghanistan or any place that
we've been for more than eight months so
I wouldn't say we we're never gonna
leave there but we have to see progress
on the ground we have to see full defeat
of Isis we have to see political process
that's why sure it's a peaceful
resolution in Syria and there ought to
be a democracy why shouldn't it who
cares about that the question who I care
about is what's happening the Christians
they're like nobody cares I don't
understand we invade Iraq is a huge
Christian community they'll leave well
who are killing the Christians in Iraq
I'm not ice of course but I'm just
saying why don't we make it an exam
annuity they're killing Chris I'm not
wrong I'm not defending Isis I'm just
saying why are we making an explicit
concern of the United States to protect
the Christians besides actually we don't
concern of the US to protect all
minorities in Syria and Iraq of which
the Christian minorities are important
part of that seem that important to
anyone here anyway I hope they are
important to me I'm glad they're
important you David thank you thank you